all right in today's eye on money
weighing the cost of college during the
pandemic with schools across the country
shifting to online learning many college
students
are trying to decide whether that
experience is worth the high price of
tuition
we spoke to a diverse group of students
about the factors
they are considering
i have four online classes and one
hybrid class
i'm going to do strictly online classes
i'm looking at uh
skipping my fall semester with risd
there's going to be a two-week
quarantine first
even after i sent in my gap year like
acceptance
i was still deciding whether or not i
really wanted to do it it's a tough
choice to decide not to go to campus i
won't have that freshman experience like
i don't want to be dramatic but it's
kind of heartbreaking when you love
school and you love
learning i realized i'm a lot better at
learning in person
rather than online i felt that my money
would be
put to better use if i were to wait for
classes to be in person
as for me it was difficult deciding
whether or not like i wanted to
actually go this year if i wanted to
like do it in person versus online
for a lot of my friends they find it
really hard
that they're paying like a very large
amount of money for
an online education and they feel like
that kind of money
could be spent elsewhere i do have some
concerns
i've taken online courses before and i
think that they're fine
obviously not ideal but i really want to
graduate in four years that's a big
factor for me
the false message is going to start
whether you're there or not i mostly
ponder on
what i expected i expected to go to
campus in the fall i expected to move
then i expected everything to be perfect
and it's just difficult because now you
have to
adjust to the unexpected
joining us to discuss financial options
for students is cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger jill good
morning
this is such a hard choice i have a
rising junior we're going through this
at home
you're paying all this money and your
kids may be taking classes online
should you consider the possibility of a
gap year in a situation like this just
waiting
until everything gets back to normal i
know so many families are having these
discussions like yours anthony
but the problem is that when we look at
college we know that of course a college
education is worth it college graduates
make more over their lifetimes
but the weird thing is according to the
federal reserve bank
that gap year will cost you get this
90 000 over your work life because
you're entering the labor force a year
later and you've taken that year off
so from the perspective of money in your
pocket
it's probably better to go back to
school of course
with the greatest precautions you know
jail there are a lot of lawsuits that
have been filed
demanding tuition refunds because
students have been
sent home effectively is there any
chance that
these people are going to recoup their
money i doubt it i mean a lot of
universities were very quick to re
to refund money for room and board
obviously last semester
but i think these lawsuits aren't really
going anywhere but that said
if your family's financial condition has
changed because of the virus you should
go back to your university
you should explain that you should try
to get another financial aid package
and i want to be crystal clear about
this when you get that package
be sure to understand what you are
getting as a grant
basically free money but what's coming
in the form of a loan i think a lot of
universities and colleges confuse these
terms
try to make sure you understand this do
try to get a discount if your family has
been impacted
there is something called tuition
insurance jill is that something people
should be considering and does it even
cover
a pandemic well it mostly will exclude a
pandemic except
if you you or your child become sick
from the pandemic
look tuition insurance is kind of
interesting i didn't know anything about
it until researching it in depth
you know there are certainly reasons why
you'd want a refund
maybe your child has a chronic disorder
maybe something's going on in his or her
life the
sort of a mental or emotional issue then
it will pay
but for the pandemic or just fear of
going back to school
that would be excluded so like many
insurance policies there's a list of
things that it won't cover
one good thing in all of this jill is
that federal student loan interest rates
are at all time lows can or
should students consider refinancing at
this point
well remember the federal government and
remember the federal government does
about 90 percent of all student loans
those are the rates that we're talking
about
2.75 for
undergraduate loans it's down by about
40 percent from a year ago
this is for the upcoming academic year
only so you might have
older loans that clearly have higher
interest rates
what's the upside of refinancing a lower
rate
but a downside of refinancing a federal
student loan
is that you lose all of those options
for
repayment income-based repayment some of
the
school forgiveness loans if you were uh
in public service
and we also you would lose that freeze
of your tuition
i'm sorry freeze of your interest rate
at zero percent
which is now frozen through september so
be very careful run the numbers
but it could be a good idea especially
if those loans are at much higher rates
so many tough decisions for students
right now jill thank you